She's cute, she
smells nice. Hey
Char,
that scarecrow is cute. She has a strange
hobby. Do
n't you think she's cute?
Well, you're here for her, right? She's
cute, cute, and you
can't leave her alone, so we're together.  I'm not interested in your thinking.It's a congratulatory
thought process.Don't
reveal your true feelings.If you're in the
same category as me, I think you think like me.I'm
not interested in your thinking.Whether you're interested or not.
In fact,
we are very close and should be together. I do
n't want to hear what nonsense you're talking about. It's a
dark chapel.
A hole was dug in the wall, and an
altar was
set up at the back. The entrance was decorated, but the ceiling and walls had been excavated.  Why do you
know why? It's just as I
thought.
If you show even a little bit of your true feelings, I can tell you.
[Music]
Why do you know about that place?
Who is he?